so i grew up in hong kong and i
did my undergraduate in hong kong and
then i went to london
to do my master's degree in operational
research
and did my phd at the wharton school
university of pennsylvania in
philadelphia and continue my journey
moving to california to join first the
school of engineering at stanford
university and then
eventually migrated myself to the
graduate school of business
i enjoy teaching
and also working in research as well as
in consulting and
support advising entrepreneurs as well
as companies
to improve their supply chain their
value chain and use the value chain as a
way to innovate
to create more values i've always tried
to work with companies and listen to
their needs and i discovered
that as companies become more and more
globalized they would have suppliers all
over the world and they would have
customers all over the world and they
have to manage
both the innovation process as well as
the manufacturing sourcing distribution
logistics
and customer service all over the world
and that becomes a complex complex
challenge not too many companies have
done it well and yet there are some that
have
and so i try to work an understanding
what makes some companies successful
what are the common lessons
best practices and what else can these
companies do
to innovate
over the years i have worked with both i
would say major multinational companies
companies that naturally in the silicon
valley high technology companies
i also have work now increasingly with
companies that are not in the high-tech
electronic world because i
find out that there are many innovations
that are also happening in very
traditional industries
like agricultural industries or like
mining industries
and there are all kinds of fascinating
lessons that one can learn
from a variety of industries i also
like to work with the entrepreneurial
startup companies
perhaps even in the developing world
because again in the developing world
in africa in india in china or
afghanistan
they also are faced with big challenges
in
the value chain and we need new
solutions
we need new ways of helping these
companies to grow
through overcoming the obstacles and the
barriers
and so that's how i also both helping
the companies
at the same time learning about how to
develop creative solutions to serve
those needs
to me an innovation is
coming up with either a product and a
process so process innovation is equally
important
so that a product that
used to be not accessible by some
segment of the market become accessible
a new way to serve those customers to me
is innovation